bienvenue à paroles autochtone cissé
mais sa marraine du puits cette semaine
j'ai reçu une question de nathalie qui
me demande est ce qu'on peut espérer
qu'un jour le savoir médical autochtone
sera valorisée au québec nathalie la
question est excellente parce qu'on sait
il ya quelques décennies les savoirs les
connaissances traditionnelles des
peuples autochtones n'était pas très
valorisé envoyé ce soit même comme
arriérée donc on n'en parlait pas mais
aujourd'hui elle commence à être
vraiment reconnue en médecine moderne et
contemporaine je donne par exemple
l'utilisation de livres du canadien qui
est un arbre qui ont dont ça beaucoup
pour décorer nos cours mais qui
maintenant ça aussi au traitement des
cancers donc beaucoup de plantes encore
aujourd'hui font découvrir des remèdes
qui sont utilisées dans les hôpitaux
cependant on parle pas uniquement de
plancton parle dans les savoirs
traditionnels et présentation des
animaux et je pense aux castors dont on
utilise les réunions pour guérir des
plaies ou même le caribou dont on disait
l'estomac pour aider les personnes qui
devaient se réalimente rey après une
longue famine
cependant si on veut valoriser les
savoirs traditionnels et les
connaissances médicales et prend la
nation il faut aussi valoriser d'où ils
viennent et ça c'est la forêt c'est
l'environnement c'est la mère celle de
love ou viennent justement ces sources
médicales qui sont utilisées donc si on
veut des médicaments en santé il faut
aussi savoir un environnement santé donc
ce serait une manière opus juste un
mauvais le récit c'est savoir là parce
que ce sont uniquement des savoirs
traditionnels des premières nations
mais ce sont des savoirs humains qui
peuvent être partagées pour le bien-être
de la population alors nathalie j'espère
que ça répond à ta question
et j'espère que vous allez nous en
envoyer d'autres espaces autochtone